[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
God all right Kay so I'm gonna need to
explain a few things a few days ago I
got surgery on my right hands that had
to stay overnight in the hospital so we
abou that I am I figured I'd marathon
all of the Dragonball specials on my
laptop to help take my mind off a few
things starting chronologically of
course with Bardock the father of Goku
well I mean I could chronologically at
least when it comes to the time you get
it no not that one that doesn't exist
the only problem is whatever happy juice
they had printable IV trip was obviously
[ __ ] with my ability to perceive and
I pretty much zoned out as soon as the
things started only to zoom back in when
I saw the end credits leading me to say
look I wasn't paying attention to that
at all so I laughed it off and I hit the
replay button because you know I
actually wanted to watch the damn thing
only to again zone out Momus later this
cycle continued for several hours as a
result Bardock seems to have seeped into
my subconscious the father of Goku now
burned into my retinas when I sleep I
dream only of barley' when I eat it
tastes of Bardock I look into my
girlfriends loving eyes and see only
Barda gazing back I fear I have become
one with this bar top special on a
biological level there is only Barda has
always been burned just Bardot
so doped up on painkillers and down one
arm I'm decided to write episode on just
Bardock specifically the differences
between Bardock father of Goku and
Toriyama's now-infamous one shot manga
Dragon Ball - not because I want to but
because I'm genuinely frightened of what
might happen if I don't only do a video
on a Bardock anyway I'm totally mutant
into turtle and this is insert episodes
lately oh [ __ ] I forgot to change the
[ __ ] script
number five okay guys so I think I've
come up with a backstory for the hero of
this comic I'm working on hear me out
basically you got this baby right and
he's no ordinary baby he's an alien baby
from a race of humanoids that look
identical to us except are much more
powerful anyways just before his home
planet is destroyed his parents sit him
in his spaceship and send him to Planet
Earth while they stay behind in Paris
with the rest of their world once the
boy arrives in Earth he's taken in and
raised with compassion as an earthling
that boy goes on to use his powers for
truth justice and the American what's
that you thought I was talking about
Goku no I was talking about the
backstory to DC's Superman as if there
weren't enough similarities between Goku
and Superman and Dragon Ball fans argue
over Dragonball - pretty much just goes
ahead and control C control V Superman's
origin verbatim the notion however that
Toriyama liked to take inspiration from
other facets of pop culture is
well-known friezes third form is a clear
homage to Ridley Scott's horror
masterpiece alien who could ignore a few
obvious similarities the story of trunks
has with the Terminator franchise
however and let me say I am no lawyer
doctor professor scientist but this
dragon ball - rewrite of Goku's
backstory is what I would consider near
plagiaristic levels of reference but I
need to draw attention to this the fact
that it is so similar to the story of
Superman is not why I don't like this
change to the series I think it's
addition serves to make the story less
special allow me to explain in the
animes original telling of a story
although not penned by Toriyama Goku
stories still had a flair of dramatic
irony to it in that Goku was sent to
earth for the purpose of destroying it
originally being born into a race of
brutal mercenaries known as Saiyans
once depicted as people responsible for
billions of deaths but because of
Grandpa Gohan's kindness and a bump to
the head Goku and
it overcomes his instincts and becomes
the champion and protector of the people
he was quite literally born to kill it's
a beautiful story and then there's - and
yeah a lot has changed with its addition
I mean obviously there's the whole Goku
Superman thing I feel like I don't need
to explain that any further so instead
let's take a look at some of the finer
details and what their reflection looks
like on the greater story this here is a
perfect example oh what's that don't
look at the moon good shout there
Bardock you wouldn't what you're saying
son to go all twos are on another planet
and accidentally murder all of its
inhabitants now would you what a
horrible thing that would be I mean it's
not like you've just literally returned
from committing mass genocide as part of
your [ __ ] day job goddamn saying that
destruction on a planetary scale is sort
of your whole bit why the sudden concern
for earth or Goku for that matter in
Dragonball - the Saiyans or at the very
least Bardock is painted as almost kind
and thoughtful perhaps even sympathetic
the reason I enjoy Bartok the father of
Goku is because of its dark gritty
depiction of the Saiyan race we've been
told time and time again how ruthless
the Saiyans were while working under
Frieza but this is the first time we
actually get to see it the Saiyans are
not good guys in fact they kind of
deserve what happens to them
it's not like they've been known to
hesitate at the thought of blowing up
another planet and it's that moral
grayness an ambiguity that makes the
story of Bardock so tragically
compelling this is not a story of good
versus evil like Dragonball Z this is a
story of bad vs worse look I've been a
fan of Dragon Ball Z pretty much my
whole life and so when I hear the word
saying often the first thing I think of
is Goku and what I think of Goku it's
easy to just remember the fun wacky
shenanigans of Dragon Ball or the
countless times he's served as a paragon
of innocence and the hope for planet
Earth
but Goku is very much the exception due
to highly unlikely circumstances he
became a very unique case the Saiyans
were scumbags and I'm including Goku's
biological family in that summation
they're supposed to care about nothing
but violence and power by making burdock
more thoughtful more compassionate it
only serves to lessen the significance
and rare occurrence that was Goku's pure
heart he's not
one in a million he's one in an entire
species and that was why I thought his
story was worth telling however now that
Dragon Ball - has taken its place as the
definitive origin of Goku it almost now
seems like rinette's is the black sheep
of the family
that's that's a weird thought but
perhaps the biggest problem I have with
- ignoring its own original story and
how it serves to in my view devalue Goku
as a character is that it just so
[ __ ] boring there's an all question
writers asked themselves before telling
a story which goes something like is
this the most interesting point in your
character's life and if not why aren't
we hearing about that instead and you
better [ __ ] believe that Bardock
father of Goku is the most interesting
point in Barack's life he and his people
are betrayed by the man they've spent
their entire life serving because he
fears the Saiyans power having been
impregnated with the ability to see the
future Barack has to avenge his friends
and single-handedly confront this evil
dictator the most powerful creature in
the known universe in an epic last stand
for the fate of his entire race and yeah
I know this is Dragonball and we've all
become desensitized to these great epic
battles and speeches but for a moment
just this once try to as best you can
imagine that approaching someone you may
have only seen for a great distance
speaking it before the highest authority
in your culture or perhaps you've only
heard of him in rumor this someone has
been a cancer spreading across the known
universe for as long as you can remember
a creature that injects fear into the
hearts of every last individual you know
personally and even those you haven't
met yet the individuals you fear with
every fiber of your being are
subservient and petrified by this
monstrous ruthless collector of worlds a
beast who if he suddenly decides it can
remove you and everyone who knows about
you from existence before you could even
process a thought that this who Frieza
is - Barda on the flipside here in
Dragon Ball - Bardock is motivated by
a gut feeling he decides that just
rocket his stunt off to some random
planet with zero protest from his wife
by the way ovary gut feeling
what the [ __ ] is this that's like my
parachuted me off to Bosnia when I was
three because my dad was getting dodgy
vibes off Bertie Ahern there are
actually people in Ireland who probably
don't even know who Bertie Ahern is now
so that's one obscure joke good luck
America
so yeah jokes aside rats who let's face
it pretty much shows up to die was given
a motivation and backstory for why he
did what he did and why he was there
looking for Kakarot but in - there's no
conflict there's not even a story arc
it's just sort of a thing that happens I
mean Jesus the writing here makes
episode of Bardock look good I mean it
looks okay that actually hurt now don't
get me wrong
none of this is to say father of Goku is
without its issues Bardock receiving
vigils of the future is pretty asinine
what's weird is that it's not even
really plot significant he doesn't
discover friezes plan to kill the Sainz
true visions of the future his dying
friends tell him after getting attacked
by freezes men and like just before
freezes men tried to kill him
so there's more than enough evidence to
support your uprising but not enough
evidence to convince other sayings which
puts you in the exact same position say
some contrived psychic powers might put
you in so in reality psychic powers make
for some cool visuals and a neat little
bittersweet ending for Bartok in the
sands but as a part of this story it's
entirely unnecessary I also don't like
how nonchalant Vegeta is about the
Armageddon of his planet I mean Vegeta
is nothing if not passionate seems a
little off for him to just shrug
something like that off so while Dragon
Ball - does have its pros like how
Barack doesn't get psychic powers and we
get to meet Goku's mom and although baby
Raddatz at the end of the day I think
it's a downgrade it retroactively ly
makes Goku's character arc less
significant but more importantly it's
just am boring - really is a fitting
name because in my view it really only
serves to subtract from what was told in
Bartok the father of Goku and yeah that
movie isn't perfect but you know what
it's damn entertaining it's got
like tan action and oh look nice move
Bardock maybe you should have taught
that trick to Raddatz overall it's a
much more compelling rendition of Barack
as a character right I like that he's
just another saying I like that he's a
dick and I like that he's the only
protagonist in anime history whose face
scar doesn't have a backstory I like
that
wait did this used to have was this a
list based video I'm pretty sure I
vaguely remember saying something with a
number at some point about something I
think uh these painkillers mostly
messing with my head I guess I kind of
let the framework for this episode get
away from me anyways drunk about my
answers [ __ ] I think I'm addicted to
opium now so that'll be fun to deal with
oh well any case I've been tentacle not
mark thanks so much for coming down hey
guys my good friend Tom helped me write
most of this video he's a funny guy and
loves video games so if that sounds
interesting to you I highly recommend
checking out his channel I wouldn't
suggest him unless I thought it was
great so show him some love anyways see
you guys next week
thank you so much for watching
[Music]